good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight there is a war on speech going
on in America your right to say what you
think as as protected by the First
Amendment to the Constitution on one
side is the entire tech establishment
and big business the HR department down
the hall from you
academia on the other side is Adam
Carolla
and a few other people luckily Adam
Carolla can hold his own we spoke to him
the other day in Los Angeles we've got
that interview after the break
worth staying for very good and
interesting but first tonight put
yourself in this position imagine being
a Democratic presidential candidate
right now it's pretty hard to stand out
in the field there seem to be dozens of
Democratic candidates maybe thousands of
them it's a huge group but weirdly they
don't disagree on much they're not
allowed to disagree
like all fundamentalist religious sects
the Democratic Party does not tolerate
dissent everyone believes the same
things the Amish have more intellectual
diversity than the Democratic field so
as a Democrat the only way to the
nomination is by winning gold in the
victimhood Olympics you've got to
convince voters that you have suffered
more than anyone else that's not always
easy for some of the candidates Cory
Booker for example hasn't suffered much
at all he grew up in an all-white
neighborhood the son of two IBM
executives he went to Stanford and then
Oxford and then yell Law School and yet
with a straight face there's cory booker
telling you all about his triumph over
racism huh
kirsten gillibrand also came from
privilege he went to Dartmouth she was
literally handed a US Senate seat just
here's a Senate seat she took it she
doesn't mention any of that now instead
she talks about sexism and the
harassment she supposedly faced you see
the point in 2019 whining is power P
Buddha judge understands that but a
judge may be the least oppressed person
ever to run for president both of his
parents were college professors voter
judge went to Harvard and then to Oxford
as a Rhodes Scholar after that he spent
three years at McKinsey that's where
ruling class drones are taught the finer
points of sucking up to corporate
but a judge got an A in that class our
system has been extremely good to P put
a judge if he's a victim then nobody's a
victim the term has no meaning
so how does Pete Buddha judge win his
party's victimhood Olympics simple with
the Mike Pence story pence you'll
remember was the governor of Indiana
back when Buddha judge became mayor of
South Bend as Buddha judge has suggested
recently this set the two of them on a
collision course Big Buddha judges gay
pence is a traditional Christian meaning
that he pines for the social structure
of the 12th century and above all hates
gay people passionately how much does
pence hate gay people watch this
explosive exchange from 2015 pence was
asked directly about Pete Buddha judge
you can see the rage in his eyes the
venom that flecks his lips Mike Pence
looks dangerous brace yourself for this
I hold a mere Buddha judging the highest
personal regard and we have a great
working relationship
I see him as a as a dedicated public
servant and a patrol whoa could you feel
the hate radiating from that man highest
personal regard
in other words Oh way from me sinner you
are filthy and repulsive great working
relationships as Mike Pence sure among
evangelicals that's well-known code for
once I establish my theocracy I will
throw you in my dungeon and let you rot
for eternity dedicated public servant
patriot oh please
Pence might as well have spit in Buddha
judges face and called him a reprobate
it's the same thing it's gay bashing now
Buddha's got responded to attacks like
these as you'd expect he warmly gave
governor Pence and I love South Bend
t-shirt and joined him on a fitness walk
but a judge wrote about the whole thing
on Facebook if you want to read the
unnerving details sometimes to this day
he seems traumatized by his experiences
with Mike Pence but a judge recently
told the crowd in Austin to quote not
judge my state by our former governor he
accused Mike Pence of social extremism
he called him a cheerleader of the porn
star presidency on CNN but a judge even
suggested that God himself disapproves
of Mike Pence my marriage to chasten has
made me a better man and yes mr. vice
president it has moved me closer to God
and that's the thing I wish the Mike
Pence's of the world would understand if
you got a problem with Who I am
your problem is not with me your quarrel
sir is with my Creator don't think that
was written by consultants at all well
you can imagine how Mike Pence responded
to an attack like that when you call out
a man as hateful as Mike Pence what do
you get in return
I hate tsunami and that's exactly what
mike pence delivered watch this
I've known mayor Pete for many years we
worked very closely together when I was
governor and I considered him a friend
and he knows I don't have a problem with
him damn those evangelicals when are
they going to learn to love their
enemies as the Bible command
Pete Buddha judge by contrast is an
Episcopalian so he expresses his
Christian faith by defending late-term
abortion and went lessly attacking
people who have been kind to him it's
more effective than talking about the
city he leads in 2015
South Bend's murder rate was almost the
same as Chicago's aggravated assaults
more than tripled since Buddha judge
became mayor rapes have nearly doubled
but people but a judge doesn't want to
talk about any of that he wants to talk
about the real victim here himself